my balcony view is so beautiful and so
peaceful i don't usually do the jazzy
stuff but why not why not eat breakfast
outside right
cardi b was having a blissful brunch
with ocean views before an unexpected
visitor joined her and completely ruined
it
[Music]
yeah cardi freaks out over a seagull who
decides it wants in on the food too and
steals her breakfast
[Music]
so much for a calm meal that bird had
other plans
we love cardi for always keeping us
laughing with her daily shenanigans we
still can't get over her explicit remix
of beyonce's break my soul
[Music]
yeah cardi girl is bold and not holding
back no
masturbation yeah
you don't wanna you don't break my phone
you won't break
[Music]
but the rapper is no stranger to putting
herself out there for our personal
entertainment she recently trolled
herself by giving the shake it tick-tock
trend a try it's cardi's collab with
dougie b and k flock that took the app
by storm
[Music]
you can't do it at home no
you can't do it at home but back to that
bird disturbing cardi's piece
it all went down in norway amid cardi's
string of performances in europe
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah the crowd was massive and seemed to
be vibing with the grammy winner all
night
[Music]
[Applause]
cardi even included her latest song hot
featuring little dirk and kanye west to
her set list she told apple music last
week the song co-written by yay came
from his heart kanye gave me this verse
a couple of months ago when he was just
you know when he was just all over the
media because you know all of this
all of the things that were going on and
um i just like how it's like i like how
his verse is like it's it's personal but
it's not that personal yeah it's like
enjoyable in the clubs that you could be
like yeah yeah you talk your big cat
we'll be waiting for more hot music to
drop but in the meantime cardi sharing
her hilarious day-to-day experiences
[Music]
is giving us life
[Music]